tout juste 25 ans est déjà à la tête
d'une marque de produits haut de gamme
initialement à la recherche d'un
laboratoire pour développer sa marque de
shampoing cette jeune entrepreneuse a
racheté fin juillet l'un des fleurons du
cosmétique made in france
le groupe pierre roger basé depuis 67 à
châteauroux l'entreprise connaissait
d'importantes difficultés financières
ma mère est tombée sur l'annoncé de
pierre oger au lancement judiciaire et
de finalement un simple le projet de
jeunes entrepreneurs
ça s'est transformé en une reprise et
une refonte totale de la marque
chirurgie c'était une opportunité on va
dire de trouver
pierre auger dans les annonces une
opportunité qu'elle a saisi avec le
soutien de son compagnon qui n'a pas
hésité à quitter un poste de trésorier à
bruxelles pour se consacrer à ce nouveau
projet non seulement c'est une aventure
merveilleuse mais en plus on a des
compétences qui sont complémentaires
donc je pense que les capacités de diana
se signalent aux mondiaux un rachat
accompagné du maintien des quinze
salariés du site
malgré l'importance de la masse
salariale de l'entreprise comparé à son
chiffre d'affaires actuel
suite à notre rencontre avec chacun des
employés on a on a dit bon à discuter
ensemble et en séance
on s'est rendu compte de leur réelle
valeur dans le processus de création de
nos crèmes et
ils sont là depuis bien plus longtemps
que nous et du coup leur savoir faire
pour nous était primordial de nouveaux
patrons qui prévoit même d'embaucher
quatre personnes de quoi redonner le
sourire à cette salariée employée depuis
45 ans elle a assisté au déclare de la
marque
on voyait bien plus beaucoup de travail
les commandes très tôt voilà des connais
pas trop mais bon je pense qu'ils sont
les reproches de nous pour l'instant ils
ont plein d'idées plein de je pense que
y'a pas de raison que ça marche pas des
idées qui vont se traduire dans les
faits par des investissements pour
rénover rajeunir et diversifier la gamme
de produits
on va continuer à travailler sur les
produits stars et les produits pour
lesquels on a énormément grandi
notamment de retour sur projet mais il
développe et enfin de l'adn pierre roger
pouvoir recréer des innovations recréer
des nouveaux produits on a des idées à
la fois pour toucher un public plus
jeune mais aussi pour toucher les hommes
le jeune couple d'entrepreneurs espère
également acquérir de nouveaux marchés
la marque est aujourd'hui présente dans
24 pays